now you know it's funny uh we were uh we
have a
a way of uh when we prepare for an
interview we look at some of the past
appearances and we were looking at one
of your past appearances and you
actually said geez louise on the show
and we were thinking
you must be one of the sweetest people
in the world because there aren't many
people around these days that will say
something like ah geez louise you know
for me except for you i'm sort of an old
woman i say good gracious and geez
louise i i um i do cuss every so often
so i'm trying to curb that by saying
geez louise and good gracious and
sugarfoot like trying to fight i've
never heard of
who says sugarfoot well instead of
saying sh right right oh i know what you
were oh sugarfoots right like in traffic
or something wow that's surreal that
you're saying those things
but you know i'm i'm trying to be a good
young woman i guess well that's very
nice that's very nice so you have the
soul of an old proper woman i do i kind
of my friends make fun of me because i
go to bed early and i sort of dress like
an old woman i like vintage clothes and
some of the the styles that i sort of
gravitate towards are kind of like giant
sacks and so they're kind of old
womany but that's all right and you
drive around on a rascal i'm
[Laughter]
a little bit too told
can you help me up there all right mandy
moore uh at 22. um okay you're very nice
person we've established that you got to
explain this cosmo cover because it's so
unfair what they did you here they have
a photo of you and then they put right
next to you orgasms unlimited
[Music]
[Applause]
did you see this i said did you see this
i'm very flattered to be on a magazine
cover but the horrifying part is my
parents have framed every magazine that
i've ever been on from the beginning so
it's there's a whole room in their house
dedicated like a whole wall right and it
starts off with me at like 14. like
mandy's favorite color is pink right
to like cosmo now with my face and
orgasms and the thing is it's nothing my
dad like taking it to the framers
through the frame it's nothing to do
with you they just do it all right they
do typical they do that sometimes i was
on the cover of time magazine a few
years ago and right next to me it was
another story but it said pedophile
captured
it was so unfair
and they were like we're sorry and i'm
like oh well
a cover's a cover you know
[Laughter]
now is it true i heard this you know and
this is this is a good thing a lot of
people not just celebrities but a lot of
people now are trying to find ways to
conserve gasoline and things like that
and i heard somewhere that you are
actually thinking of buying a car or you
actually have bought a car that runs on
vegetable oil i have yeah i haven't
picked it up yet i actually i'm going
back home today and and i get to pick it
up but
is this like a is this a car that that
anyone could could get yeah i guess
there's now a conversion kit for all
diesel cars that you can convert the
engine to run on biodiesel or soybean
oil so i just bought this old vintage
car like an 80s vintage car and
um it's going to run on soybean oil so i
i'm waiting for like that paparazzi shot
of me uh at mcdonald's like at the end
of the night stealing their french fry
oil like yeah look you're looking
horrified siphoning it into my car
they're just like us well you know
what's funny is that i've yeah
isn't that nice
it's not nice she's just like me
so so i've heard that and this is it's
it's amazing these cars really run just
as well as any car and you can pour
like fria later oil into them but it
ends up smelling the exhaust smells like
the food that it sold me on the car the
guy i it's just like really cool no
seriously um it's this really cool like
um um company in los angeles and i went
and was like looking at the cars and the
guy turned on uh turned the engine on
one of the cars and he's like guess
where we picked uh where we got the oil
for this car and it smelled like
mongolian barbecue and i was like i'll
take it
i wanted it it was so cool anyone
passing by just sees mandy moore sucking
on a tailpipe
what's she into
poor girl
yeah i've heard about that and you like
they you just put french fry oil in your
car and drive around and the only
downside is your car has a heart attack
like after two years exactly you have to
have a bypass
now uh of course uh your very successful
acting career you even did you did a
guest spot on scrubs was that i did i
did it was a lot of fun i'm such a big
fan of the show i think it's it's really
smart and
um i was going on of course and i was
playing the love interest to my
boyfriend on the show so i figured i
would have to kiss him on the show and
at the last second they um they sprung
on me that i would have to uh kiss sarah
chalk who is the female lead on the show
and i'm very good friends with sarah
and it was just a very last minute sort
of thing and and we both were like well
all right let's do it so i sort of had
my first girl on girl kiss on the show
wow
then you found out later they weren't
even there was no film in the camera
just sitting there do it again
i've done it nine times i know uh
where's the crew they had to go
but you had a good time because that's a
really funny that's a really funny cast
an amazing cast i had a great time yep
now let's talk about american dreams
this this is a cool idea you're you're
playing it's uh it really is centered on
an american idol type show basically
patterned on american idol and you're
playing one of those
people that's aspiring to be uh an
american idol you know contest winner
and so i'm just guessing because all the
cast members i mean you you have an
amazing voice you can really sing but
that set people must have been hanging
out everybody's singing probably
backstage the whole time you're shooting
this you would think that but no
actually none of us really sang except
um all of the extras who were sort of
playing the the other contestants that
were supposed to be uh on this american
idol type show they were all sort of
waiting in the wings singing like
whenever they could kind of like hoping
to be discovered but little did they
know that it was scripted and and they
weren't really making it onto the show
like further in the movie so i i always
found that to kind of be funny right
well since
you'd laugh at them i enjoyed like
singing and stuff and i kind of felt bad
because i was like well you guys aren't
really making it onto the show look onto
page 42. yeah you're not you guys aren't
in the script right right have you ever
thought about what you would sing if you
were an american idol contestant like
what songs you would choose i don't know
what i would sing um maybe something
like carol king and i probably i don't
know i probably wouldn't make it that
far because it's not like you know
jazzy enough or something for the show
jazzy i'm such an old woman what am i
talking about
no no it's fine i'd sing something
upbeat and fast like a k kaiser song uh
uh
yeah but i think everybody watches that
show anyone who turns on that show
subliminally puts themself at one point
or another like they think about what
they would do if they were there i
haven't but i just i love watching
people not doing a great job that's my
favorite part of the show well you're a
cruel cruel person
we're finding out a lot about you i'm
not a nice person after all no i'm
obsessed with the show in all honesty
but it is kind of fun to watch people
that's a guilty pleasure a lot of people
have total guilty pleasure and that's
why they show all those clips of people
coming on and the best part like the
first couple weeks when it's not the
actual competition it's just the
audition reels of people right that's my
favorite right yeah i like the way
people work in all the vocal gymnastics
and songs that they don't really require
it doesn't yeah you know they're they're
doing that mariah carey thing i don't
know if there's a name for it but
they're singing like the star spangled
they're like
i'm gonna start doing this on the show a
lot we got mandy moore on the show and
you're looking fine
i'm gonna do that
i like it
i just tore something in my hip